speaking of houses last thing i want to
talk about is miami uh you have a house
here
um you are one of many people who came
to visit
uh i think kind of as like let me go
check this out let's see
um and then you're like no i'm actually
gonna move and i remember you dimmed me
and i was like wait is he kidding
like like no way he just got here like
three days ago and then you're like no
no like seriously like i'm doing it
so walk me back to you tweet while in
san francisco you get retweeted by the
mayor and he's like how can i help it's
this whole thing now
what's your perspective on the whole
miami thing and like your role in this
yeah i mean we originally started
debating like where would we open a
second office in like july 2020 because
keith was really looking to like leave
the bay area
and finally maybe like september october
we like settled in miami he like bought
the house decided to move
the entire time i was just like dude
like how is he going to be as like top
tier investor how are you going to win
really competitive series a's like this
in-person stuff really does matter
that's going to come rebounding back
like
it feels totally impossible and then in
december it was just like sitting there
and this is like in
deep in the ground of varda you know
what i mean like i've been working on
like basically pulling the company from
scratch dealing with all the
you know uh convincing the co-founders
that we should work on this equities
play it's business plan fundraising et
cetera it was like
it was rough doing that while also
trying to do my founders fun job at the
same time like i felt like i was working
crazy hours
the one thing that was keeping me sane
was i could go have outdoor dining at
the [ __ ] wild seed restaurant next to
my house it was like a nice way to like
cap the night
and i remember just seeing the like you
know announcement of like we're shutting
down outdoor dining and i was like
sitting on the can i was like are you
[ __ ] kidding me
there's no scientific evidence that
there's any outdoor spread why are they
doing this if anything's going to make
things worse
because i guarantee you people have now
started to become accustomed to being
social outdoors
now they're going to all go all indoors
it's going to be even worse than if you
just cap the outdoor dining
and so i sent what i thought was like
very obviously a pithy tweet to my
followers because i've been tweeting
about like anti-miami things for the
past
like you know month and like arguing
with keith about it like publicly and i
was like oh
[ __ ] it like what if we just like picked
up silicon valley like moved to miami so
we don't have to deal with like outdoor
dining stuff
and then you know lo and behold like the
mayor quote tweeted it and he was like
you gotta come visit like this went
viral blah blah and i was like dude like
i just started this company and like
we have 14 people that are starting like
in our la office on like whatever jan
19th
i don't have time to [ __ ] like think
about a miami trip but anyways varda
sort of got off the ground we got
everybody onboarded we had this first
you know whatever board meeting early
march
and like keith's birthday was like you
know second or third week of march and i
was like you know
maybe i could afford to go like visit
miami for a week go check it out i
remember talking to my girlfriend like
that sunday before we were
like there's no [ __ ] way we're moving
like varda's in la
like all my friends are in san francisco
keith's totally wrong about this thing
like there's no way
and then over the course of the week a
couple like you know crack started to
appear in my argument like you know on
wednesday i remember like going
out to dinner with keith and just like
looking around the restaurant be like
jesus like this is like uh the deck uh
which is like this you know restaurant
that's actually
like pretty close here and i was like
this is a more vibrant and happy
and like laughing like lifestyle and
vibe in this restaurant
than like even like the best restaurant
and like choose your favorite evening
san francisco whatever you want new
years anything
it is like less fun and less happy than
like how happy i feel right now
and i care a lot about being happy
because i think it does make you like
work harder and found that in miami that
i work a lot harder
and then the following night i went to
this like uh tech party that you were
also at like whatever in march where i
just walked in the room and i remember
just being like oh my god
there are more top-tier vcs builders
like you know engineers founders
in this room than what i've seen in san
francisco for years san francisco used
to have these like very fun ostentatious
parties like i remember like 2014-15
going to these like crazy pool parties
in woodside you'd see like
everybody all these types of builders
and like it sounds kind of silly but i
actually do think those parties are
important
because like those spontaneous
interactions sometimes lead you know
somebody who maybe works in space they
talk with a d2c ecommerce thing and
turns out there's actually
some sort of collaboration and like when
those sort of parties started to get
canceled over the course of like you
know canceled culture in san francisco
you just lost out on that and so people
didn't have these like spontaneous
interactions nearly as often
and i do think that's quite important
like i remember from that party in march
i knew that like six or seven
investments happened like multiple deals
got signed like a lot of things happened
from that party and i walked in and i
sort of like i said it originally as a
joke
to a friend but then the moment the
words left my mouth i was literally like
i don't know how the [ __ ] i'm getting on
the return flight to san francisco
and the moment that hit and i said it
like i had not been thinking about it
until that moment
and then i said it and i looked at my
friend i was like oh my god i'm moving
to [ __ ] miami
i was like i think i am and then nadia
by the way my girlfriend was having a
completely
like parallel experience where she had
actually left miami for two days to go
to disney world with all of her friends
and i kind of describe her as like you
know she's much more like the public
intellectual writer researcher like much
more you know creative than i am smarter
much smarter than i am
you know she was having this parallel
experience where one all of her
like friends had already moved to miami
and she just felt like her like
creative energy was so much more
unlocked by being this place that was
much more intellectually diverse
physically diverse so many more colors
and beauty
than she was seeing in san francisco and
so she had actually been having this
whole discussion with her friends as she
was driving back down from disney world
for like this dinner that we're gonna
have friday night together where she was
like oh my god i need to have this like
very serious conversation with dallian
we're like i want to spend more time in
miami
because i'm really happier here and i'm
enjoying it here and i know he really
loves san francisco but like i really
i can't go back to san francisco i need
to be like spending more time here and
she's like arrives to dinner and it's
like
dallian i think we should spend more
time in miami and i just like replied
was like i think she just moved to miami
she was like
what i was like i think we should just
move and i was literally like we
basically like didn't talk about it
after that we were like great we're
moving to miami i was like
that was the extent of the discussion
then sunday morning we woke up took a
vesper around the city went to a couple
of open houses
and basically like bought the like you
know second house that we visited and
we're like great put in the offer the
next morning
and you know started planning the move
and that was the extent 48 hours from
you know deciding to uh
uh moving what was keith's reaction when
you told him
um he was at first i think like almost
like uh in disbelief that like it
happened
um but there was actually a sort of nice
text that i got where the actual moment
that i texted him
um that we got the offer accepted he
actually happened to be on a zoom call
uh with a like mutual friend of ours the
mutual friend said like that was like
the happiest he'd ever seen keith in a
long time
uh so it was nice to you know as i said
get that text i i
i feel like he really really stuck his
neck out there like put his reputation
online and said hey like this is real
and your story is very common
where even myself i came and i came
because i just wanted to get out of new
york for a weekend
right yep and then i was like wait this
is like weird like
i think it was uh mateo and alex from
asleep
uh steven from cameo keith like like
there was and i was like wait a minute
like there's
way more people here than i thought
there were and then we came back the
next weekend
uh for a whole week and i was like are
we gonna do
like you you almost are like am i
getting tricked like like what's the
catch exactly
and then the it's funny you say
happiness that's how i described people
i say i'm a happier miami that
encompasses a whole bunch of different
things
uh i don't know if it's the sun if it's
the people if it's just the environment
if it's the diversity of
you know kind of this is like the
capital of south america some people
describe it
whatever it is i do feel like people are
happier and
uh there's higher energy and some people
look at that from a work perspective say
i work harder some people just look at
like it's a higher quality of life
yeah i mean for me i'm like all i care
about is you know my number one goal in
life is i want to be one of the best
investors of all time and i want to
build a lot of very big space companies
over the course of my career
and when i'm happier i just work harder
and so i just i can't imagine like ever
deep prioritizing that and like moving
somewhere else
in miami because she's like there's no
[ __ ] way i like work harder here than
i did in san francisco moving back would
involve like compromising my
productivity and i have like zero
willingness to do so
and then yeah also it turns out like the
weekend's a lot more fun and then part
of the reason i'm also much more
productive is like
i'll work a 12-hour day and then like
you know san francisco if it was 9pm
it's like
you're going home all the restaurants
are closed you're uber eating like some
shitty burrito and like you're watching
netflix like your girlfriend
versus here at 9pm it's like i can go to
mila i can have a quick like one hour
meal and by the way there's like fire
dancers a dj
i'm having a great [ __ ] time and like
what i've realized is like this took me
a while to figure out how to articulate
like why it was so refreshing
is because when you're in that like
burrito netflix watching mode in san
francisco it's kind of still like the
same
dahlian that was like the work delia
like it's not like change
versus 15 minutes or so into mila like
for sure the first 15 minutes i'm still
kind of in like in work mode and then at
some point you just like
have so many people laughing around you
and the lounge music and the fire
dancers
that about like 20 or 30 minutes in you
just kind of transform into like what i
call like
vacation dallian and it's like you're
happier and you're excited and all the
stress and like the [ __ ] that you had to
deal with all day like totally melt away
and just being able to sort of have that
like literally like daily reset of like
having everything just totally melt away
allows me to like then approach the next
day i feel like a much fresher clearer
mind
and like work super hard again everyone
in san francisco knows the tech industry
is there
and everyone's in tech and therefore
like you go to the bar everyone wants to
talk about work stuff right
especially if you're public on twitter
like if somebody sees you at the bar
like hey let's start with this oh space
founder fun whatever i gotta start up
let me pitch you like all like all the
craziness
here nobody gives a [ __ ] exactly like
literally there's not a person in mila
who gives
a [ __ ] about the tech industry they're
literally here from
every industry all different cities uh
some people from the united states not
from the united states whatever like
there's there have a good time
and i think that's what you're kind of
getting at is like you don't feel like
everywhere you go
from the coffee shop where you see all
the vcs uh and founders to then
work to then you go to a restaurant and
then you go home and you do it all over
again like it's just
you just are seeing the same people that
are in the same industry over and over
and over again san francisco and miami
is completely different there's such a
melting pot here in so many different
ways right like i love the fact that you
have people that are like
barry stern like one of the best real
estate investors operators of like all
time
you have thomas bravo one of the best pe
firms of all time you have like antonio
gracias one of the best deep tech
investors of all time and you have keith
right boy one of the best like fintech
healthcare attack like
you know more consumer venture investors
of all time those never were ever like
it was impossible to get all four of
those types of people in one room
anywhere in the world because like the
likelihood of them actually coordinating
travel or going to the same conference
is quite low
whereas in miami that happens all the
time so you both have this like
intellectual melting pot but then
obviously also you have the like
cultural like diverse melting pot like
what i love about miami is like
nobody's talking about race because
there's just so many different people
from so many different types like why
like nobody it's not even like
ridiculous to even like talk about it
versus go i went back to like san
francisco this past weekend for like a
friend's birthday and i remember
it was like shocking to me like i walked
on chestnut street literally for like
five minutes
and like the thing that just kept going
through my head i was like there are so
many
[ __ ] white people here and i never
appreciated it until like now living in
miami
where like now it just feels like so
jarring where i'm like oh my god
i just like my olive skin does not
[ __ ] fit in here and now i get why i
feel so much more relaxed in a city of
immigrants that is much closer weather
to bulgarian weather where like nobody
asks me who i am where i'm from et
cetera because it doesn't [ __ ] matter
everybody's got a weird name and has a
weird accent and like has you know weird
colored skin
if it doesn't [ __ ] matter nobody's
gonna ask you about it nobody's gonna
judge you based off it
versus san francisco they're all [ __ ]
looking the same and they're the ones
that are constantly talking about like
racial politics
critical race theory and it's like the
only reason you guys are talking about
that is you'll [ __ ] look the same
i wish i had a microphone you could drop